well you not only do a lot with a look
in this movie and do a lot with a
whistle
indeed I do you can let me hear the
whistle oh you want to hear too much now
I know a song everybody wants to you
know it's a good Wizzle you know I like
to get away do you want to hear I think
ya can't blow it are you just gotta
control it from your diaphragm
alright I'm swinging I'm gonna have to
work on that
look out let's talk about your makeup
for a second they change the process a
little bit this time only did you weave
it but it was not it was just an
addition which cut down the time for me
and added a different base that allowed
all the other colors to be more easily
removed however actually feel on your
stand like this confetti even why how do
we it's like skin I forget it's there
and I am once it's on and I go in I
gotta tell you I tell people this all of
them and I expressed these feelings my
makeup artists and my team I looked
forward to getting into work every day
it's three boorish hours before anybody
else in our before other people that
don't have the same type of makeup I got
up and I was ready to get to work last
question for you they announced volume 3
James Caan talked about directing it if
you were going to suggest a song for the
volume 3 mixtape what would it be
how about almost anything from paint
senior okay what's that he says welcome
to the frickin guardians of the galaxy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you